it is practically the only survivor
because of this competition to take
at first from the Maghreb and a few
years later Asia
we said to ourselves stop we stop the new
one we move on to something else
in the 80s until 82  we
stopped the big production of the workshop
let's say at the time he wants to stay 30 or
40 people
we went to two three people my
two brothers and I from 520 days
we fell to 150 years it lasted for
years
my son  julien said dad i have a friend
to take offs and her fabulous it's
a pride an honor
we can't too much union
in the european union defended yesterday
gave us after about 65000 euros
it allowed us to make a  beautiful workshop
helped enormously we develop the speed
of development calm sea of ​​zain de
mire the sleeve and two people and next year
I think that if you come back
to see us in europe almost more
than doubled so we make our vests the
sheep from here  the room it is cultivated
on the sets there is no longer a handicap
as the iphone is more isolated
thanks to the internet we are at the center of the
world time exceeded 35 nationalities
china russia south africa it's
really the whole world and may it last